le lait de volts igol va permettre à ce
petit garçon de voler comme un aigle
dans la maison à verre de lait d'autres
sortes de l'est aux pouvoirs
extraordinaires sont présents j'ai
préparé un petit peu d'émotion
particulière avec le lait de vache du
lait entier pasteurisé forcément j'ai
rajouté un petit peu de pouvoirs
magiques dedans pour donner de la
couleur et pour avoir des effets
différents on peut devenir rond comme un
ballon on peut grandir comme une vache
en l'espace de 15 secondes jusqu'au 1er
novembre de 14h à 18h des animations
autour du thème d'harry potter sont
proposés le but est de découvrir quatre
maisons la basse cour avec des oiseaux
et leurs yeux les différentes qualités
de la laine chez les moutons la traction
animale chez les chevaux et les
composants du lait chez les vaches le
côté magique et le côté scientifique les
expériences les expérimentations le côté
ludique sont des choses qui sont très
appréciés au niveau des enfants
justement les enfants devaient participe
à de nombreuses épreuves diverses et
variées ils devaient remplir un carnet
magique tout au long de leur aventure
il y avait une épreuve où fallait
trombone potion j'ai choisi
volontairement
une somme deux fois ensuite dernière
étape de cet après-midi hanté coloré
avec la peinture à base de comme les
activités sont diversifiées
ils ont pas le temps de s'ennuyer du
coup et ça tourne beaucoup en fin de
journée un match quidditch est aussi
organisée l'idée de ces animations
halloween est de faire découvrir en
famille la ferme et ses animaux
la soirée lampions frissons et
dégustation prévue mercredi 21 octobre
et quand elle annulé à cause du
couvre-feu